so who benefits from this ruling yeah
it's primarily hospitals because they
were writing off upwards of thirty
percent of their revenue for folks that
didn't have insurance pretty Obamacare
so now these folks can keep their health
insurance and hospitals can rest easy
because this was basically incremental
revenue that they weren't getting before
so it's a big deal for hospitals
insurers as well but more hospitals okay
so if there's new how do you price this
in well it's going to be a positive for
all these stocks especially as a
previous guests stated the hospitals and
also the insurer's it's a huge volume
play for many dis players especially the
managed care firms so if there was an
issue here as far as subsidies go from
any of these state exchanges and it was
ruled unconstitutional you would have
seen some moderate headwinds here as far
as growth goes from any of these
healthcare related firms over the next
several years Jason the exchanges that
exist some of them are state-by-state
some of them are run by the federal
government what does this ruling have to
do with those exchanges in the future
yes oh this ruling essentially impacted
the 34 states that had federal exchanges
this essentially means that all
exchanges have access to these tax
credits so folks basically they don't
have to worry which state that they're
in so this ruling could have gutted the
ACA so now there's really no concern
they're all exchanges it doesn't really
matter what the definition is they have
access to health insurance and that's
good for really ensures as well as
hospitals to Vishnu you know as we've
seen with this market reaction I mean
pretty much all across the board green
for for for any company related to
health care but you know outside of the
short-term impact and removing that
uncertainty you know what about the what
about the long-term holdings who's going
to benefit in the long term and where
might the headwinds be from here yeah
definitely well there's always going to
be head winds and tail winds and any
legislation that passes Congress however
this really benefits the insurer's
longer term it's a good volume play for
them 30 million uninsured coming into
the market
gives them a huge amount of revenue
stream they may come in a lower level
profitability so that's where the
headwinds come in from any of these
players so the profitability from any of
these plans will be a lot less than what
they've done historically however from a
growth volume perspective given that the
employer market has pretty much matured
it's a huge win for them but again I'll
circle back the hospital's went out one
hundred percent because they are able to
have some reimbursement here finally for
some of the uninsured folks they're
going to service Jason what does this do
to the managed care providers is so
basically they can continue servicing
their clients so more consolidation in
the industry I mean we've got the cigna
bid that's out there I mean just mean
that they're going to consolidate even
more yeah they could because they don't
have to worry is to like you said
whether it's exchange plans or it's the
individual markets and for them bigger
is better and it could also mean that
they want plans in different states and
that's part of the reason for the anthem
Cigna bid are there any losers here at
all at this point I think that's really
only if you figure on any pressures
longer-term from this law but for the
most part it's really wins for for the
hospital's only only do they have some
reimbursement cuts but they've already
taken that hit so this ruling is really
a positive Vishnu if you're the chief
executive of a pharmaceutical company
and you're looking for growth and
worried about people trying to cap the
amount of money that you make is this a
good ruling it's pretty much neutral I
would say they're still going to face
some reimbursement pressure here moving
forward especially with the large size
of the pharmacy benefit managers here
see of Express Scripts CVS now
unitedhealth playing a key role in terms
of determining what the pricing is for
pharmaceuticals so that's outside of the
ACA the ACA will definitely again be a
moderate tail and for most of these
firms on average again because you're
bringing a lot of uninsured and you're
making sure that you're getting
reimbursed at the end of the day for the
services and products you provide to
these uninsured you have her the Vishnu
that you know the rubbings are
Republicans are not going to give up
they may revive this issue in 2016 so
you know even though this seems
overall like a benefit and that the
issues put to rest I mean in my arise
again so is that a contingency plan here
for that well I definitely believe there
is something there was something in play
if the Supreme Court were to rule the
other way today however that doesn't
have to come in come in to factor
anymore longer term when you take a look
at the political wrangling the political
back and forth definitely when it comes
down to the Supreme Court and the law it
looks like it's settled now the only
other issue could be if you have a
Republican come in to come into office
here and try to repeal the law however
the likelihood of that happening I'm not
a political analyst but likelihood of
that happening is not necessarily too
high